[Music]
a lot of these fights are symbolic lunch
counters water fountains those weren't
the most pressing problems facing the
Civil Rights Movement but but they can
be powerful symbols when you're trying
to trying to change the way people view
a certain minority and trying to assert
the rights uh so I think I think it's
important to look at it both both and we
we run into this problem all the time I
mean in in the freedom from religion
Foundation what we do you know we're
fighting symbols constantly 10
Commandments on public land crosses on
public land and those are important
fights to have uh for that very reason
so I I think it's not necessarily just
about the bathroom and it's not
necessarily about a non-issue kind of in
the way that it's not necessarily about
um baking a cake or you know getting
giving flowers to a gay wedding in that
that Arena um which I think you and I
disagree on that yeah all right let's go
there so my P I feel that if this person
has a Rel religious belief and they
don't want to bake a gay wedding cake we
now live in a time where either you can
get a cake at another Baker perhaps in
your town or one town over but people
said to me well what if you don't uh
live in there's no bakers near you
anywhere we also live in a time where
Amazon can pretty much deliver you
anything anywhere and I just don't like
the federal government coming in and
demanding that they do something that's
against their belief that that's just my
my belief
that's what about like the state
governments doing it so for the Oregon
cas is all the Oregon Baker case it's
all state government that's that's
happening so lay that out just so the
same page and everyone knows exctly this
is this is a a gay couple went into a
bakery uh Sweet Cakes by Melissa I think
the name and wanted uh them to bake a
cake for their gay wedding uh they said
no we love Jesus more than you we're not
going to do it uh and this the state
civil rights body actually they made a
the couple made a complaint to the state
civil rights body and they said yes um
you know you you have to do this because
our law doesn't allow you to
discriminate on the basis is of sexual
orientation um and and that was that's
been the case that's making its way up
to the Oregon Supreme Court so so I mean
you're it's are you kind of more in the
a market-based solution type my gut
feeling on this is more of a
market-based solution so I get what
you're saying in this case it's
specifically the state not not the
federal government so I do make that
distinction for sure unfortunately I
would say you know I had Randy Barnett
who's a constitutional law professor at
Georgetown I had him on the show and he
mentioned a phrase that I love which is
the foot vote that then if you don't
like what your local area if it's your
local town that the baker is bad in or
if you don't like the the state
government of Oregon in this case you're
allowed to move and that's the beauty of
our system I know it kind of sucks like
it doesn't feel right believe me you
know what I mean a lot of people I got
gay people that were emailing me saying
you know I'm not happy with you on this
I know it doesn't feel right but but
every excuse for just more government
control I don't like and because we live
in a time where you can get a cake a
million other ways and you can move and
take your money and the worth that you
bring to your community and all of those
things that's just where I would fall on
this well well let let me make let me
make the case and I think I think
there's two things so for all these all
the kind of the market-based ideas the
market based solutions to to these
issues they all are premised on the idea
that people producers and consumers and
I'm first of all I'm not an economist
let me lay that out right now okay okay
they're all premised on the idea that
producers we'll put that big under your
name not
producers and consumers behave logically
and they make decisions most importantly
logically and we just know that's not
true exhibit a is religion exhibit B is
Trump people vote against their
interests all the time and Exhibit C is
the case itself right the baker is
turning away perfectly good money right
so they're they're not behaving
rationally or logically in terms of of
Economics wait let me pause you there
for second because I think in a way that
also strengthens my argument which is I
think that 99% of people in business are
in business business to make money and
99% of people would not let their
religious view override their view to be
successful so in other words if you
opened up a coffee shop and said we
first well first off not serving people
is different than not doing a specific
action that they want you to do but most
people are in business because they want
to make money and I think that we're
we're making such an issue out of a tiny
little thing there so continue well that
it dub tailes nicely with my second
point so one of the things that I that I
do at ffrf is I go all around the
country and I talk about kind of issues
and right now there's an attempt to
redefine religious liberty um it's it
kind of is the biggest example that
people might be familiar with is that
the Hobby Lobby decision that the
Supreme Court made a couple years ago
it's turning it's weaponizing religious
liberty instead of being this this right
for you to behave a certain way and to
to do a certain thing it allows you to
impose your religion on others that
that's the the change that we're seeing
in the law that that we're fighting
against and one of the clips that I show
when I give this talk is a a CN n uh
report they went to a small town in
Georgia Georgia was considering passing
a religious freedom law that would have
helped with this this redefinition you
may remember it there was a big backlash
against it um NFL said we're not going
to come there all these companies yeah
so um I showed this this video and uh
CNN went to u a small town they
interviewed florists in that town and
would you serve a gay couple absolutely
not and they went every single one of
the florists in town said that
right so it's so a lot of florist
gay that's a whole other issue but how
many Flores like no I'm not gonna do it
well you and actually one of the guy one
of the florist's son was going into the
Seminary and uh I I'll post the video
somewhere it's really good it's worth
watching it's online right yeah it's
we'll link to it below on this okay I'll
um so the I mean now it's not a big deal
right for if you can't get flowers for
your wedding it's not it's not the end
of the world but but if that's food or
gas or you know formula for your baby
then that becomes a real issue and and
maybe it's not being gay maybe it's
being black or maybe it's being Jewish
and maybe it's not just this town maybe
it's the town next over and the town
that's next over and you're right the
times have changed but if that sounds
absurd to people like they have to
remember that that's the whole reason
that we have the Civil Rights Act in the
first place you know in King's
Birmingham letter from the Birmingham
Jail he wrote it in I think April of 63
he even talks in there about having to
spend his spend nights in his car on a
CrossCountry road trip in the
uncomfortable corners of his car because
he couldn't no Hotel would let him stay
there yeah and when Kennedy proposed the
Civil Rights Act when he made his speech
I think it was in the Oval Office in
June of 63 and one of the first things
he says is that everybody has to have
equal access to places of public
accommodation it was the whole purpose
of this because we were effectively
creating an entire second class of
citizens by not allowing them to
purchase gas or to to get a motel room U
and it it's it's incredibly problematic
I think it's appropriate for government
regulation yeah so it's interesting
because look if there was a gas station
that said we're not giving we're not
serving gas to black people or Jews or
Muslims or whatever else it is or white
people even though they're not a
minority at the moment but if they know
they were just picking something based
on discrimination just for the service
that they offer everybody sure I think
there's a there's an exceptional argu to
be made there absolutely the case with
the cake I think is a little bit
different because they didn't say we
won't sell you a cake we won't sell you
a cake customized to this specific thing
that is against our religious belief and
in this case even though I'm against
their religious belief I just think even
in the case of the florist so okay you
go you go to all the florists and every
I mean all these florist saying no to a
gay wedding C is kind of hilarious I
feel like somebody gets to do a spoop of
that but then ultimately it would be on
you to order something from 1800 100
flowers or to to just move but I I see
what you're saying is perfectly
principled and again this is where I I'm
not going to force my beliefs on you in
any way like you know I I like and you
may not know this either uh you know
ex-muslims of North americ s haters yeah
they actually uh they were denied a cake
at a bakery in Virginia and she called
me yeah and I wrote a letter to the the
company and actually they got a cake out
of it wait quickly but they so they
wanted a cake for a for a Muslim way to
celebrate no
being Muslims oh right right right I did
see this one or two years their
anniversary of their organization yeah
and they weren't they were the I guess
there was a Muslim worker in that Bakery
I don't remember the name of the chain
um that the and whatever the name of the
chain was they did they did a great job
when I wrote to a corporate they they
hopped in the gear and said that
shouldn't have happened we're we're
incredibly sorry here you go he was in
here was in a c so basically it was one
worker who happened to be Muslim he saw
them celebrating their you know
anniversary of of the ex Muslim
organization the company then did the
right thing corre you either have to
suspend or fire this guy I mean I'm not
what do you think about these exceptions
now that we see private companies doing
where you know uh you know I've seen
this several times like a Muslim flight
attendant doesn't have to serve alcohol
or you know something of that nature
yeah I mean I I don't think that that
well for a private company they can do
whatever they want if they if if that's
the way they want to accommodate
somebody's religion they they're I think
it's just a terrible accommodation I
would be with not hiring that person if
you're a flight attendant and your job
in the job description serve people what
they want that we have on this plan I
would be 100 that's not discrimination
you're looking at a breath of what they
can do and I would be for just not
hiring that person the the scarier
version of this is actually happening
right now in in the federal law so the
religious freedom restoration act that's
what the Hobby Lobby decision was based
on and and that is saying the same kind
of thing except it's saying that your
religion allows you to be exempt from
General and neutrally applicable laws
because your religion that's it the
Hobby Lobby case was fundamentally about
providing bth birth control and the
Hobby Lobby owners the owners of that
company said these are aborti they cause
abortions and therefore they are against
our religion that is 100% wrong that
belief is not accurate it is
scientifically they are not abort of
patients and uh the Supreme Court got a
brief from 60 or 70 medical and
scientific organizations saying this
belief conflicts with fact okay and the
Supreme Court didn't even address it
they said they believe they believe that
they are abortive Fati therefore they
get to be exempt from having to provide
them reality didn't matter so they ele
what the Supreme Court did was they
elevated a counterfactual completely
unsupported belief Above the Law just
because it's labeled as religious
because it's held with unshakable
certainty and that's that's what I'm
talking about when I'm talking about
redefining religious liberty that is the
scary scary fight that we're seeing
right now it is taking these
unsubstantiated beliefs and allowing
people to be exempt from the law because
of it and the the Supreme Court dealt
with this issue back in 1878 from a
constitutional standpoint they said that
if we do this if the first amendment
allows you to be exempt from any law you
want just because your religion says so
we're have chaos it's Anarchy I mean
everyone would start their own religion
exactly government is pointless don't
even don't even bother yeah there you go
exactly so to have to have people doing
that it's it's unworkable um but this is
all based on a law the religious freedom
restoration act not the Constitution so
that's actually good news because if we
repeal the law it gets rid of the Hobby
Lobby decision but instead of doing that
what you're seeing now is more laws
being proposed right now you're seeing
the First Amendment Defense Act which
takes rifra the religious freedom
restoration act a step farther and says
that yeah even discrimination which is a
little unclear under RI go for it you
can discriminate in the name of your God
it's not a problem at all it's 100% okay
so it's this is a it's a very scary
fight and it's
also it's also short-sighted I think
this is one thing that never gets talked
about that that's a little frustrating
to me the religious right is so
shortsighted in their strategies um and
there there are plenty of great examples
of this
um the the the prayer before government
meetings that we were talking about the
reason they fought for that is because
they were all Christian prayers we're
start now the Supreme Court has said
that you can't just have Christian
prayers they have to be anybody
including an atheist right we're
actually suing Congress so that our
co-president can get up there and give a
secular invocation before Congress right
uh and you're seeing the satanic temple
getting up there and giving invocations
before Town meetings in Florida and
people are going bomb so that's really
the shortsightedness because they've
been fighting for it when was when it
was to the exclusion of everyone else EX
suddenly the same law as it gets widened
you're not going to be so thrilled
exactly and you see it everywhere um
another great example is the equal
access act allows students to form
student clubs in school and it was
passed specifically because the court
said kids can't form a religious Club in
a public school that's that's uh not not
under the Constitution you can't do that
so they passed the equal access act
which says that if you allow kids to
form any club they also have to be
allowed to form a religious club and now
that's being used for every atheist Club
in the country every LGBT Club in the
country is using that law to form but
the the scarier version of the
shortsightedness is when it comes to
things like Muslims and Sharia law and
things like that like it the exemptions
apply to everybody if if people are
would that be the ultimate irony it
would be and if people are genuinely
worried about that like this is there's
there's this big fear you know uh Sharia
Supremacy uh and Frank Gaff is pushing
this idea that you know that Islam is
this it's this totalitarian political
ideology it's not a religion so we
should we it's okay to treat these treat
Muslims not as we would treat other
religious people the point of all this
though is we already have the solution
to all of these issues and it's called
the separation of state and church like
they should be fighting alongside ffrf
not against ffrf you know and that that
is the easiest way to to not have any of
these problems in the future but yeah
that's why I would always he on the side
of anything that would strengthen the
Constitution anything that would
strengthen the laws that we live by
which is actually a perfect segue to
where I wanted to go here which is so as
a guy that that believes in law that is
a lawyer that you've referenced Supreme
Court decisions often you know what
you're talking about all this stuff how
scary is it to you that this is that the
Supreme Court the way we appoint
justices now even at the state level
that it all is becoming insanely
politicized the whole point of
separation of church of separation of
powers was to keep this stuff from being
over overly politicized but now it's
like they almost everyone in Congress
votes on party lines uh we know all
kinds of shady stuff goes on behind the
scenes by the way on both parties
through pressure when Obama wanted to
get ObamaCare passed when Trump now
wants to get this this thing passed that
we're politicizing things that are
supposed to be apolitical most
importantly the Supreme Court I mean I
think yeah the entire Federal Judiciary
well not just Federal the entire
Judiciary throughout the the country is
that it's a very scary development and
the the the scarier thing is the money
that it's going into State elections for
judges is is insane and it's it's
incredibly scary and you know I mean how
are you not beholden to a company that's
put2 or3 million into you know getting
you elected how are you not beholden to
that that company when they come up in
front of you on a case and of course
that's the reason they're doing it in
the first place of course they are like
let's let's not let's not be they're not
just giving money away children they
like money exactly I mean so I think I
think the the the politic politicization
gez of judges and the Judiciary is is
very scary and very problematic I mean I
think to a certain extent it's always
been there but it does it does seem to
be worsening right now and especially at
the the the lower levels um I mean the
the federal Judiciary the Republicans
are really really good at holding out as
they've demonstrated with Garland and
now Gorsuch they're really good at
Holding Out for what they want they're
they're better at playing the political
game than Democrats are for sure um and
they're they're changing the court
system and Juris Prudence because of it
um so that's why they're doing it
they're they're effectively winning but
it's also I mean it's almost in a way
it's almost scarier at the the state
level especially if you're just an
average citizen that's where that's a
lot of those decisions are going to
affect you far more than than some of
the Supreme Court decisions yeah is
there anything on its way up to the
Supreme Court right now that people
aren't really thinking about that we
should should be thinking about there's
two cases there right now um there's one
which is is an amazing case um it's out
of Wisconsin actually and it's it's
about political jry manering so Jerry
manering on to further the Republican
party and if the court strikes just real
quick for people that don't know what
Jerry mandering is I mean it's basically
redrawing the map the local Maps so that
they favor one candidate or or one party
or correct and and it's um it's been
done very effectively by the Republicans
in the last couple rounds of Elections
they they redraw the maps every 10 years
I think based on uh the the census um
and this is challenging it on it's been
struck down before on in terms of race
um you know you can't can't favor um
whites at the expense of
African-Americans say to vote the idea
is every vote should count you shouldn't
have wasted votes and right now they
could strike down there's a case before
them where they could strike down
political Jerry manering um the second
case is out of um Minnesota uh it's
Trinity Lutheran and this case actually
will it'll be do serious serious damage
to the separation of state and church
basically a church applied for public
money they would have been given a grant
I don't remember how much doesn't matter
how much we'll just say $10,000 doesn't
matter at all it could be a dollar um
$10,000 um to to revamp their
playground and the government said no we
can't give you money you're a church
like you have to do this on your own
that's you know there's a separate of
state and church and they're suing over
it and if that decision goes the wrong
way that that what possible grounds are
they suing they're suing on they're
suing on saying you're giving this money
to schools and other secular
organizations uh to allow them to revamp
their playgrounds you're discriminating
against us because we're religious um
which the separation of state and
church is discrimination in a way except
it's deliberate right and it's okay
because you also get all these benefits
from the separation of tax exempt and
they have membership right I mean they
have people that pay into the church
it's for the church to do what they want
with that money and they're tax exempt
they got a pretty sweet gig there's so
much more than that too not only are
they tax exempt and this is amazing to
me they don't have to submit anything to
the IRS you want to be a tax exempt
Church you just say I'm a tax exempt
church and then every single year so for
instance ffrf we hire an outside audit
company to come in and audit our books
every year and we submit this form 990
to the IRS it's it's huge it's honorous
it takes like a week to complete and it
tracks every penny that goes in and
every penny that goes out of the
organization churches don't have to do
any of that we have no idea what kind of
money comes into these places no idea
what kind of money goes out they're
they're completely exempt and they also
have crazy other benefits under the law
um Ministers of the Gospel quote
Ministers of the Gospel that's the
phrase that our law actually uses can
take money that their Church pays them
as individuals that's designated for
housing and they don't have to pay taxes
on that right it's just completely tax
exempt they as individual employees get
complete tax exemption as long as uh the
money's designated as a housing
allowance that's it um so so there's a
hilarious iron well it's a depressing
irony I suppose which is so they're not
paying taxes and yet they're also
bringing a lawsuit that would say we
want tax money to do something and at
the same time our books are completely
closed so for all you know we got 5
million in the bank yeah
they want to have their cake and eat it
too and and this is the other push that
you're seeing in the law and they're
actually using a lot of the language of
free speech they don't want they don't
want any of the burdens that come with
State Church separation yeah um but they
want all the benefits so they want all
the benefits of State Church separation
and then all the benefits of free speech
and all these other things they don't
want to take any of the burdens that go
along with it and that that's another
big fight that we're having but that
case is is genuinely terrifying because
if if if the Supreme Court says yes you
have to fund
this that opens the floodgates of tax
money going to churches it's never been
done right it just I mean it's simply on
its face forgetting my feelings about
religion or anything like that just
simply makes no sense because they're
not paying into the system I suppose
maybe you could make some argument if at
the very minimum they were paying taxes
into the system and then they wanted
some of that tax money back or something
like that although that sounds kind of
crazy too but the other part makes no
sense uh is there anything going on
related to that right now in the legal
system related to getting tax exempt
status taken away
from these things this is one of the
things I think for for atheists or
non-believer or even for some religious
people that view you know when they see
the Mormon Church putting money into
fighting gay marriage a
political thing political event the
biggest thing with that right now is
something called the Johnson Amendment
and the Johnson amendment is a very
simple rule is passed in the 50s and
what it says is that churches cannot
engage in partisan politics they cannot
appear to endorse or oppose a specific
political candidate it doesn't prevent
them from talking about issues they can
still talk about gay marriage they can
still talk about abortion they could
talk about civil rights if they wanted
to nobody ever wants to so they're
they're perfectly able to do that right
so they can subtly do it ex well they
can talk about issues right that's
that's fine what they can't do is just
endorse or come out against a a
political candidate or you know maybe a
specific Bill something like that
sometimes so it's it's it's partisan
politicking that's prohibited yeah when
I say subtle I mean you can basically
tell people what you as soon as you said
it what popped into my head was when uh
Rick Santorum was running um you know he
always used to wear those sweater vests
he appeared in church next to a pastor
and the pastor was dressed exactly like
him with a sweater vest and all that you
know just Winn yeah wink wink nudge
nudge kind of thing um so the way that
that the amendment is structured is it's
tied to the tax exemption so it says if
you want to be tax exempt fine you're
able to but you can't do this and it
applies to all 501 c3s all nonprofits
and all churches as well and churches
are saying no no no no that's a burden
on our free speech and you have to let
us endorse people otherwise you're
violating our free speech and it's not
they're faced with a choice you can
endorse people if you want you just
don't get to be tax exempt and I think
the thing that people don't realize I
mean the Johnson it's so unsexy and so
boring like how do I get people
interested in this but it's if if it is
repealed it is it's going to be
terrifying if you think citizens united
was a bad decision this is 10 times
worse 100 times worse again because we
don't know what kind of money is coming
into churches and what kind of money is
going out they will effectively become
completely unregulated completely dark
Pol C cpacs they will be these black
holes of financial information and power
that people can just funnel money into
gobs millions I don't think it's absurd
to say billions of dollars will go into
them yeah and then they can spend it on
whatever they want I mean so it's not
about Free Speech when you hear about
the Johnson Amendment and repealing it
it is not free speech it is about money
and power which is something that
churches have been off after for
Millennia W uh we could do this for so
much more time so you're definitely
going to have to come back but is there
is there anything major that I missed
here that would put a nice bow on all
this if we're just talking about the
state of everything yeah I I think so I
think that you're like yes there's a lot
actually people yeah we I could do has
it really been an hour it's been an hour
oh okay yeah so people should join the
freedom from religion Foundation first
of all I mean that I think that is if if
you care about these issues and you care
about the separation of state and church
we are membership organization you know
and I I certainly want their membership
dues but more than that I want their
voice your books are open by the way
yeah and people can see every form 990
it's online but but I I want people's
voice to be joined with ours you know
when when I write a letter to that
school district on behalf of that Mom
and say you know this teacher needs to
stop praying it's great when I can say
we have 1,200 members in Florida or we
have 5,000 or 10,000 we have 27,000
members right now but the more people
that join us the stronger our voice
becomes and I I again you know I just I
keep coming back to that the
shortsightedness of of the religious
rights strategy right now secularism has
worked for this country it is not a
dirty word we invented the separation of
state and church this is like this is a
quintessentially American thing it's
inin in our constitution everybody
should be supporting this it is it's
your patriotic Duty uh so I yes so come
come join ffrf help us in this I thought
you Heathen atheists don't love country
ORS we've been accused of B often yes
but not how it works yeah I only stand
up and fight for the First Amendment
every day so you know did we get some
good ideas out here cuz Life's too short
to waste on back you know what I'm
saying I hope so yeah had a lot of fun
well it was a pleasure talking to you
I'm I'm glad we finally got to do this
in person and we'll we're going to do
this again because this stuff's it's
just not going anywhere no it's not
we're gonna be here for a while all
right very good uh for more on Andrew
and his work check out his website
Andrew
elel.com
[Music]